three after almost two years of
restrictions nevada's mask mandate is
now over it is the first day that
teachers and students are going to walk
into the classroom today without a mask
governor sysolak lifted that mask
mandate less than 24 hours ago hector
mejia live now from a local school
hector you know a lot of people though
are still divided on this
that's true and this is now a personal
choice in classrooms that includes
cashman middle school here right behind
us but no matter how you look at it it's
been a hot button issue since day one
and beginning today masks are no longer
required on ccsd campuses schools or
facilities during governor steve
sisselak's announcement yesterday he
reminded folks the pandemic is still not
over however he thinks now is the
appropriate time to repeal the mask
requirement according to adam's place a
non-profit that helps children and their
families cope with loss and grief
there's a good thing out of this
children will be able to improve their
social skills
children are like sponges as they're
growing and and the body language is no
different and they haven't had that
opportunity to do that as much in this
last two years
however some believe the governor acted
too quickly some of the parents we
talked with want to have the option to
keep their students at home if they
don't feel safe and as students return
to class this morning there is one place
where the masks are required and that is
on school buses reporting live hector
mejia live local now